- Chris is rockin'
some cool kicks.
- That is interesting
that I do have cool shoes.
- It's good, that
is interesting.
Yeah, that's a good ending.
- I think that's probably
a really good place
to leave the season.
(funky electronic music)
- Hey everybody, welcome
to The Other Show.
I'm Sarah.
- And I'm Chris.
- And we're here
talking about the finale
of The Other Two with
Case, Helene, and Drew.
Hi you guys.
- Whoo!
- Hello!
(clapping)
- [Chris] The season's over.
- [Sarah] We made it.
- The season's over.
- A whole season,
I can't believe it.
- You said this was
gonna be more subtle!
- I did, and it is!
- He is wearing a literal
birdcage full of birds.
- But not real birds!
- It was actually really
fun to come to work
and see what you were gonna
be wearing every episode.
- Yeah, you were like,
"I'm excited for it."
- 'Cause you had some
amazing wardrobe.
- Yeah, it was cool.
A couple days before we
did all the costumes,
they bring all the
costumes to my house
and I tried 'em all on.
And I'm like, "Okay."
- Yeah, Jill Bream
did the costumes.
And is incredible, and
does costumes at SNL, too.
And then sometimes she
would show us something,
and we were like, "I
don't know what..."
And she was like, "Trust me,
"when it's on him,
it'll be correct."
And it always was.
- My favorite was
the Versace look,
with all the gold chains.
- Oh, yeah!
- Episode eight, and like the
crazy jacket on the plane.
- At the club, yeah, yeah.
The birdcage outfit
was funny, too.
I didn't know what
to expect for that.
They were like, "You're
gonna wear a birdcage."
And I'm like, "What?!"
- And now, performing live
for the first time ever,
give it up for Chase Dreams.
- Whoever does that
VMA VO is like--
- The actual--
- Yeah, the woman
who does the...
- Yeah, it's like--
- The actual woman did it?
- It's like, "And now..."
Was so good, it feels very real.
- Yeah, she was great.
- Yeah, we did it with her,
and she did a couple, and
she was like, "Any notes?"
And we were like, "No,
that's what it is!"
- [Case, Helene,
Drew, Sarah] Yeah!
♪ Dancin' 'til we stink
♪ Ain't a party 'til you reek
♪ So dance until you stink
- This episode was
Chase's big performance.
- Yep, yep.
- We went to the
studio with Case,
and recorded that song,
and then tweaked it.
- Yep, and then we
tweaked it a little bit.
(Sarah and Case laughing)
- I know it was very
weird to be like,
"We need you to sound
bad, but not comedy bad.
"Believable bad."
So you had to--
- Yeah, can't be like
a goofy bad, it can't be like
it's obvious you're
missing notes.
It has to be natural,
a little bit.
- Yeah, so we had to record it,
and have you kind of miss notes.
- Yeah, kinda miss notes.
- And then try some
where you'd sing it well,
- [Case] Push it a little bit.
- And then we would mess it up.
- [Case] Yep.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- Was that bizarre to do?
- It was, when I went in there,
I didn't really
know what to expect.
But I was like,
"Okay, I kinda..."
'Cause I've seen
people in real life,
you know, mess up
on awards shows.
- [Sarah, Chris] Yeah.
And it's like, it's still good,
but it's like, "Nah,
that wasn't right."
It wasn't, in my opinion
when I was in there,
I was like, "Oh, it's
not that hard to do."
But it was weird to do.
It wasn't hard, it was
just weird, you know?
- Yeah, we wanted it to be just,
almost imperceptibly off.
- Subtle.
I feel like if Chris or
I performed on a show.
(Case, Helene laughing)
- No way, I'd be way worse!
- Are you kidding?
- You could do it.
I don't even have anything
to start with.
(Sarah laughing)
- What is Twitter saying?
- Um, that we're (beep).
Every Tweet is bad.
The Burger King account is,
like, ripping him apart.
- My son is a good singer, okay?
He just doesn't have
an ear for music.
So what?!
- Have either of you
guys biffed it so hard
live, or anything?
(Sarah laughing)
- I have.
I did Wicked on the
road, and a couple times
went up on my line in
front of barn houses
with like 4,000 people.
- Well that's especially crazy
because then you've done
that show 1,000 times,
and you're like, "How
can I randomly..."
- Well, if you've done
a show 1,000 times,
you start to like,
while you're doing it,
your brain can go so
many different places.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- 'Cause you've said
those words so many times
that you're thinking
about something else,
and then you're
like, "Oh my God,
"I forgot about Helene on Earth.
"She needs to remember what's
coming out of her face."
- [Sarah] Whoa, that's trippy.
- And then if you
start to be like,
"I've done this so many times,
"I wonder what would
happen if I forgot it.
"What would happen
if I forgot it?
if I forgot it?"
And then you're like, gah!
- I haven't really
acted since college,
like every gay person.
(Sarah chuckling)
But I still have dreams
to this day of like,
going up on a line.
Have you biffed it hard?
- Yes, yes.
(Case, Helene laughing)
- And that's the
end of that answer?
- That's it.
(Chris, Helene laughing)
Many times, still happening.
All of my YouTube
videos are biffs.
(Case, Helene laughing)
- Oh, what do you think
mom's career news was?
- Who knows.
(dramatic instrumental music)
(twinkle)
- We were trying to figure out
how to end this season for
a while, and we were curious
about how to keep the
premise of The Other Two,
you feeling like the others.
So we came up with the idea
that Molly would be famous
now, that Pat, the mom would...
You kind of slowly but surely,
you see, like, "Oh,
it makes sense,
"she has been taking advantage
of all these opportunities."
- I loved that
teaser at the end.
I would watch Pat.
(Sarah, Chris laughing)
Especially 'cause it's like
Molly just being Molly.
- I would too, yeah.
I do think this looks real.
- I was like, "Yeah,
I'd watch that."
- Yeah, that's good.
- Molly Shannon
on a talk show?
- And I was like, "Why
isn't this a real thing?
"Let's make this a real thing."
(Drew chuckling)
- [Sarah] Yeah, let's do this.
- I'm glad you're all here,
because I've been thinking,
and I have a big announcement.
All this singing stuff
has been really cool.
But this fall, I'm gonna go...
To college.
- What?
- In this episode, you two
become even more
connected to Chase.
And you hold their
future in your hands,
and you don't know it.
- Yeah, you don't know
that she's your manager,
and that he's your co-star.
- Well, I'm so innocent.
I'm like, "What's goin' on?
"Oh, their whole lives
are depending on me?
"What?!"
Yeah.
- We think it's interesting
moving forward if he has said
he doesn't wanna
do this anymore.
And if the family makes him,
- Yeah.
- Or doesn't make him, or,
you guys all need
him in a way, now.
Where that is tricky.
- Mm-hmm.
- Where it's like, that
was never your intention
going into it.
- [Case] Yeah.
- I dunno, that kinda
stuff would be interesting,
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- [Chris] Of like--
- And then I don't
wanna do this stuff,
but they're kind like,
"No, you have do.
"Please just do this
one thing for us."
- Yeah, that you're
the breadwinner,
you are the reason that everyone
has the things they
have accidentally.
- Yeah, that's one of
the reasons we have you
be like, "Brooke and I
will always listen to you."
'Cause it does set
up this premise
that he's your little brother,
and you guys will listen to him.
- Yeah.
- And then immediately,
that's tested.
- Yeah.
- I wonder if they'll
rise to the occas'.
- We'll see!
- Or be garbage people.
(funky electronic music)